Traductor: Sarah Ponce
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
La princesa Savitri del reino Madra
era tan benevolente, brillante y radiante
como el dios sol por el cual fue nombrada.
Su gracia era conocida en toda la tierra,
muchos príncipes poderosos y mercaderes
ricos acudían al palacio de la familia
para pedir su mano en matrimonio.
Pero al ver su brillante esplendor
en persona
los hombre perdían su valentía.
Poco impresionada con esos pretendientes,
la princesa decidió encontrar
a un esposo por su cuenta.
En su carroza dorada
atravesó desiertos sin fin
brillantes ciudades y montañas nevadas
rechazando a los hombres
que se encontraba.
Eventualmente, Savitri se aventuró
en las profundidades de la jungla,
donde encontró a un hombre joven
cortando madera.
Su nombre era Satyavan, y amaba la
tranquilidad del bosque tanto como ella,
pero la princesa se percató
de que él no estaba en paz.
Después de hablar por horas
Satyavan le habló de su sufrimiento.
Sus padres una vez
fueron ricos gobernantes,
hasta que su padre perdió la vista
y lo derrocaron en un violento golpe.
Y ahora Satyavan trabajaba sin descanso
para mantener su nueva vida sin dinero.
Su determinación y devoción
conmovió a la princesa.
Al mirarse el uno al otro, ella supo
que por fin había encontrado a un igual.
Savitri corrió a casa a darle a su padre
las buenas noticias,
pero lo encontró hablando con Narada,
un viajero sabio y el mejor
mensajero de los dioses.
Al principio su padre estaba feliz
de enterarse de Satyavan,
pero Narada reveló una trágica profecía:
su prometido tenía un año de vida.
Savitri quedó helada.
Había esperado tanto para encontrarlo,
¿estaba destinada a perderlo?
La princesa no aceptaría esos términos.
Juró ante Narada, su familia,
y ante el mismo Savitr que nunca
se casaría con otro.
Él era el amor de su vida y sus destinos
estaban entrelazados para siempre.
Conmovido por estas poderosas palabras,
el sabio le dijo a la princesa que
siguiera un viejo régimen espiritual.
Con rezos regulares, periodos de ayuno,
y la preparación de hierbas
y plantas especiales,
tal vez podría prolongar
la vida de Satyavan.
Tras una boda sencilla, la pareja
volvió a la jungla para vivir
siguiendo las instrucciones del sabio.
Esta modesta existencia estaba muy lejos
de su lujosa crianza,
pero eran felices con la
compañía del otro.
Pasó un año y el esperado día llegó.
En su primer aniversario, el sol
estaba terriblemente caliente,
y la frente de Satyavan comenzó a arder,
Savitri apenas pudo arrastrarlo
a la sombra,
antes de que se pusiera tieso y frío.
Con los ojos llenos de lágrimas,
vio una figura inmensa en el horizonte.
Era Yamraj, el dios de la muerte,
que había ido a llevarse el alma
de Satyavan al más allá.
Pero Savitri aún no se daba por vencida.
Siguió al dios durante horas
bajo el calor extremo.
Yamraj le gritó a la princesa
que lo dejara en paz.
Pero aunque sus pies sangraran y su
garganta ardiera, Savitri no volvería.
Eventualmente, Yamraj se detuvo.
Le concedería un deseo como
premio a su persistencia,
pero no podía pedir la vida
de su esposo.
Sin pensarlo dos veces, Savitri le pidió
que devolviera la vista a su suegro.
El deseo fue cumplido
y Yamraj siguió su camino.
Pero seguía escuchando
los pasos de Savitri.
Harto, el dios le concedió
un segundo deseo.
Esta vez, ella pidió que el reino
de Satyavan fuera restituido.
Y otra vez, el deseo fue cumplido,
Yamraj comenzó el descenso
a su reino subterráneo.
Pero al ver atrás,
le impresionó ver a la desaliñada princesa
siguiéndolo al más allá.
Jamás había visto tal devoción
a los muertos,
y honró su dedicación con un último deseo.
Savitri pidió ser madre de muchos hijos.
El dios se lo cumplió,
y se despidió de ella.
Pero la princesa repitió el voto
que había hecho un año antes:
se destino estaba entrelazado
con el de Satyavan.
¿Cómo podía tener muchos hijos
si Yamraj no le devolvía a su esposo?
Al escuchar esa buena pregunta el dios
cedió, admitiendo la derrota.
Con la bendición y respeto de Yamraj,
Satyavan fue devuelto a Savitri,
juntos caminaron de vuelta a la tierra
de los vivos,
unidos en un amor que ni siquiera
la muerte podía destruir.